wer es nicht einfach so flück trumpf
leide krampus komme ich gefühl
[Musik]
hier in diesem tiermarkt ingo hahn hat
alles begonnen
das neuartige corona virus sprang vom
tier auf den menschen über anfang
dezember wurden die ersten infizierten
in die spitäler der stadt eingeliefert
am 23 januar dann der shutdown
die elf millionen stadt johann wurde
hermetisch abgeriegelt im epizentrum der
epidemie zehn schweizer unter ihnen die
berner studentin fabienne blaser
[Musik]
so ganz ist die angst situation in
kontakt mit der schweizer botschaft und
dann kehrt das allem haus bei mir
gemacht werden schweizer aus der region
evakuieren
im dauer einsatz für das schweizer
fernsehen china korrespondentin claudia
stein diese apotheke gehört zu jenen
apotheken die jetzt täglich masken
erhält die sie an die bevölkerung
verteilen kann
shanghai hier lebt und arbeitet claudia
stangl seit sommer es china und ostasien
korrespondentin der stasi gesichtsmasken
und smart tv uster ist durch um
luke ist da genauso gut ist so seit
ausbruch der epidemie ist claudia straße
beinahe rund um die uhr arbeiten heute
realisiert sie einen beitrag für die
tagesschau thema der maske notstand in
shanghai johann ist 700 kilometer
entfernt doch auch hier in shanghai
leere straßen viele bewohner der stadt
sind für das chinesische neujahrsfest zu
ihren familien gereist wer noch in der
stadt ist bleibt zu hause
denn auch in shanghai gibt es über 180
infizierte und einen toten nur in den
apotheken herrscht hochbetrieb
dollar
man kann
wo man sonst ja ich war schon dreimal
hier um osten zu kaufen
jede person konnte maximal zählern osten
ich habe keine masken mehr bekommen
ich war zu spät sie waren schon
ausverkauft zum dritten mal diese woche
nächste woche wird es sicher besser
werden ich habe vertrauen hilfe der
regierung
mit fabian und homos bahn und im moment
in buchheim
juni lediglich jeder tag love liebe
messer und das neue magic und des musik
in das online formular über 6,1 grad
also kein problem
so ganz ist die angst situation ist dann
vielleicht spartak fordert langsam
bewusst wird okay das ist die sicht
frühling sind marios 70 sogar otto dix
stadt karachi nach fahrer ohne einige
taxis aber die rosa und castro großer
supermarkt vom campus ist also zum
einkaufen muss man entweder sie ins
internet lag außerhalb von campus zum
nächsten großen offenen supermarkt in
dem gebäude wo kann ich die situation
seit einer woche organisiert die
städtische behörde in shanghai täglich
eine pressekonferenz zum thema corona
virus eine ungewöhnlich proaktive
vorgehensweise
kritische fragen von claudia stein
ausweichende antworten der zuständigen
behörde die einheit in elxleben machte
keine beschlüsse zum thema masken und
das hier machen sie um das beheben ganz
konkret werden momentan wegen des
frühlingsfestes sind viele facharbeiter
in den ferien wieder normalbetrieb
herrscht können wir garantieren dass
genug mussten produziert werden
immer so bewusst warum das so eine große
krise heraus ist für die kommunistische
partei und hotel spitzer und shipping wo
es gibt es auch wieder die parteispitze
und bevölkerung das quasi hotel hirt
aufgabe für kluge das ist bevölkerung
gut geht und da gibt es natürlich in
gefahr des corona videos und bekam so
viel masse umzug 2010 wissen dass sie
das grimmsche am anfang vor dem ganzen
sache überzeugt wenn es einer schafft
die krise griff zu
er wird es garantiert als großer held
der geschichte in china selber verkauft
oder verkauft mir sieht die jeweils
geschafft hätten die krise bewältigen
ihre mitarbeiterin tieren ist für
claudia stangl unentbehrlich sie
übersetzt die aufnahmen von der
pressekonferenz und sichert den kontakt
zu den behörden und protagonisten doch
ist ruth unbill die bewegung braucht es
darf wieder verloren
ich hab die bewilligung meine antrag
wurde genehmigt antrag wofür um wieder
zu arbeiten
also dann kannst du morgen mit kommen in
die masken fabrik
claudia stahl steht in engem kontakt zu
fia gerber einem der zehn
eingeschlossenen schweizer in der region
rund um die stadt wo an
ich bin zu ziehen da wo in der provinz
hubei in china und sie darf ich mit
uncle und mit meiner frau aus der stadt
stammt wir verbringen jedes jahr in
davos
und hand aufs neue jahr verbraucht
das kriegt man das kontrolliert er
irgendwo und irgendwie discobetrieb da
liegen sich der spital- und der heißt
der hartz iv infizierten personen hier
interessierte personen für die ganze
stadt und staat hat
sie lieben
es ist grenze vor der fusion also von
bezirkstagung zum conchita vom skibezirk
und david ferrer straßensperre das mini
kann nach morgen schütten erfahren
damit widmet nicht ja ne dumme reise
dann nicht sich nicht bewegt
hier im zürcherischen furcht leben
pierre gerbes tochter und ihr mann peter
piak erbe heiratete vor zehn jahren
seine zweite frau die chinesin warschau
das corona virus scheint vor allem für
ältere menschen gefährlich zu sein
ja ich glaube hat sache unterschätzt
kaufe ich den täter nicht richtig
informiert sie und mir mehr hand
russland harry panik noch die wahl
unterstützt indem er überhaupt sich gar
keine sorgen gemacht hat und jetzt
entwicklung auf ein anderes hört sich
dann irgendwann mal überleiten es sündig
völlig wert und bin ich natürlich fragt
sie wollte ich zurück schweiz mit meiner
frau oder not und unter psychischen
druck wenn er natürlich kaum hat ist
erst einmal meine frau metro schaffen
wir sie überhaupt und was machen mit
manche kinder haben weiß vor allem nicht
wie lang das es gar das ist finde ich im
winter sind ein faktor wenn man will
sagen die zwei britisches baby dann
halte man das gut tun aber wenn das dann
sieht man wenig chaotisch es wieder mit
besonders und was ich mir halt auch
nicht so gemacht ist dir die neue mittel
jetzt im moment sechs aufgebaut so dass
es sie dass supermärkte vor ort und
machen alles kaufen
aber wenn es dann länger gott wie geht
das
[Musik]
in der eu - und da ich kein spinat und
durch ist wird jetzt nach dich fertig
sein
die linken sind ja auch in die
einkaufstasche windjacke und gas sind
hier
ja ja schon plant aber fest mit einem
militärflugzeug abgebremst dass man muss
alleine flog afro und niemand weiß wie
das immer landschaft über die flughafen
ist andere abstimmung mit dem auto vor
ihr entfernt etliche fahrer wirklich
fertig und es geht nun mal spezielle
taxis pro region am rund laufen wird
ungefähr zeitung und doch nicht
zwischenrang
und das waren die folge
das war eine oft genug
speziell aus
wann ich das nochmal verlieren blaser
will man so schnell wie möglich
verlassen
der 27 jährigen berner studentin setzt
der alltag in quarantäne langsam zu
claudia stahl teilt ihr einen direkten
kontakt zur schweizer botschaft mit
[Musik]
kontakt
die zeitverschiebungen shanghai beträgt
sieben stunden sind die
nachrichtensendung des schweizer
fernsehens bedient ist bei claudia stahl
schon wieder früh am morgen und die
recherchen für den nächsten tag beginnen
vor dem fertigstellen des beitrags
eingang in die shopping-mall um
kaffeekapseln und lebensmittel zu
besorgen
[Musik]
öffnet der pastor der working poor und
natürlich okay
[Applaus]
die vertriebe da ist sie denn mit dem
fitnessprogramm wurde helsana plus heute
stunde 30 d januar
meine frau hat jetzt gerade im chat
klasse das in davos privatauto nimmer
der für dumme fahre
das heißt dass man gestern gemacht hat
ich hätte immer möglich erlaubt seien
nun nur noch offizielle fahrzeug also
krankenwagen feuerwehr polizei und lud
wo wir bei kontrolle machen oder sucht
sachen überprüfen
freunde irgendwo im spital schaffen und
die hat er jetzt gerade mitteilt dass da
wo jetzt 16
infizierte personen hat 16
noch einmal vier leere wasserflasche und
will heute auf der straße nur traurige
kommenden darauf den straßen nicht die
talaat ich werde mir keinen aufschub
erhalten betreffenden wasser neben reis
mit dem mit dem hsv
ich kann jetzt e mail über auf oder
schweizer botschaft und zwar betrifft
das die die mögliche evakuierung von
schweizern risiko offen blieben ist hoch
und es wäre auch möglich dass wenn man
dann irgendwo hängen blieb nehme zurück
zum ausgangspunkt zurück nach drei
wochen die und dann ist es so dass mini
frau als chinesische staatsangehörige
notwendig wäre als das war für mich
möglich und aufgrund von der situation
auf will zurzeit ja kein auto der
verfahren im glauben habe ich
beschlossen
ich bin da wird mit meiner frau und
mitten im angriff als erstes gefragt
pause evakuierungs möglichkeit gibt ihr
wollt mit ja und wo haben solar und die
hat es bestätigt das stand im moment
sorgt des botschafters also keine
möglichkeit
[Musik]
und darum versuchen sie mit der
französische und deutsche botschaft
arbeiten wo es schwierig ist alleine in
bistritz bringen im moment chinesische
tätig war beschäftigt ist
[Musik]
shanghai am freitagmorgen an der
pressekonferenz vom mittwoch deponierte
claudia steil bei der städtischen
behörde den wunsch mit der kamera bei
der produktion von gesichtsmasken dabei
zu sein
flugs wurde die besichtigung eines
entsprechenden betriebes organisiert wo
sie jedem außerdem organisiert
die finnische mehr direkte und die
andere hälfte sie als land mit gelegt
ja kräftig medusa black harry angst
hatte dass die zahlen explodieren sie
ist riesig vor schweizer sicht der
macher denken stoppen
mitglied im connect dem recherchieren
für musikalität treffer säuberung
wachsen
stauffer morgen danke schon was machen
und es ist einfach kein platz für
mehrere lektor hat jetzt angst offen ich
hatte mir das trage jährige empfiehlt
für shanghai 200.000 masken pro tag
werden hier im 24 stunden schichtbetrieb
produziert normalerweise wird ein
großteil dieser masken ins ausland
exportiert jetzt bleibt die gesamte ware
im land die stadtregierung gibt vor wie
viele masken ausgeliefert werden und
wohin aus den medien habe ich gehört
dass in der provinz hubei ingo horn ein
neuartiges virus aufgetaucht ist
ich habe 2003 sass erlebt und 2005 die
vogelgrippe damit 2008 die
schweinegrippe 90 was auf uns zukommt
ich habe sofort alle arbeiten und die
kapitalgeber zusammengerufen
was ihre reichen 24 stunden tag und
nacht
niemand kann sich zurzeit aus
hey hallo herr zwei ja super news ist
daran tisch kommt es ganz schwierig es
nicht so einfach ist es autos
organisiert und er ist natürlich und
anstatt dass man hundertprozentig gemäß
der flug verpasst also ja ich weiß noch
nicht so genau
wenn sie früher gehabt das wichtigste
sitzen nicht mit der botschaft dass das
französische konsulat in und das ist
also definitiv ist die alte fahrer
update nur mal am 2 da musste ich noch
irgendwie als abholer und oma fahre nie
besser packen wird dem organ irgendwie
noch gar nicht mitgerechnet
stella von kreuzau irgendwie großer
geschmissen habe eigentlich buch ist gar
nicht erst februar ihre großmutter sie
bringen
ciao haben viele kranke gibt es jetzt
aktuellen tagen 54 und außer 450 und
meine hand jetzt nachricht hört vom
spital das hört wenige retreat hat als
sie der letzte tag vielleicht wäre dass
es zeichen dass der der da steglich
jetzt sind da wo mit denen maßnahmen wo
stadtregierung vorhanden
fabian blaser konnte wo hahn gestern
abend verlassen
nun steht ihr noch eine zweiwöchige
quarantäne in südfrankreich bevor hier
gäbe es hoffnung auf entspannung der
lage hat sich zerschlagen
in seinem quartier wurde heute ein
krankheitsfall gemeldet claudia steil
ist schon auf dem weg zur nächsten dreh
noch gibt es keine helden geschichten zu
erzählen
[Musik]